Roosevelt and I speak of theater of
course and Wilson openly boasted that
they were not obliged to follow the
words of the Constitution that as
president they could make changes on
their own I'm Nikolas be with reason TV
and today we're talking with Judge
Andrew Napolitano whose latest book is
Theodore and Woodrow how two American
presidents destroyed constitutional
freedom judge thanks for talking with me
here Nick in previous books things like
lies the government told you it is
dangerous to be right when the
government is wrong and dred Scott's
revenge you looked at different eras of
American history in the way that freedom
was kind of eviscerated by you know
various politicians and powers-that-be
now you're talking about Theodore
Roosevelt and Woodrow Wilson and the
progress of the earth why does the
progress of Europe matter so much when
we're looking at shrinking of Liberty
the radical change in the relationship
of the federal government to individual
Americans was ratcheted up greatly in
the Progressive Era if we can go back a
little bit there was no relationship
between the federal government and
individual Americans until after the
Civil War and then the military
occupation of half the country known in
some quarters as reconstruction resulted
in a direct personal relationship
between the federal government and
individuals during Reconstruction for
example you couldn't go to the post
office without permission from from the
military and a lot of other draconian
measures you couldn't build a house or
expand your house or repair your house
and there well Sherman burnt it down
without permission from the fact that
was in the former Confederate States yes
yeah yes now in the Progressive Era we
find a Republican and a Democrat
collaborating together even though they
barely met and didn't really like each
other the changes in that time period
are radical and they all center around
one thing and that is the Constitution
somehow empowers the federal government
to right any wrong regulate any behavior
and tax any event whether it's
articulated in the Constitution whether
it can be extrapolated from the words of
the Constitution or not Roosevelt and I
speak of the
of course and Wilson openly boasted that
they were not obliged to follow the
words of the Constitution that as
president they could make changes on
their own so you have two presidents who
believe this is a radical difference
Nick from all of their predecessors even
Lincoln that they can from the White
House order and direct changes which
will affect the lives of every American
Roosevelt started the FBI on his own
without any budgetary appropriation or
legislation from the Congress Roosevelt
bought vast swaths of federer of private
property or stole the property from the
states because didn't pay the states for
it and claimed this is now a federal
land you did all this without the
consent or legislation from the Congress
Woodrow Wilson arrested people because
of what they said about the world war
what not what they did about World War
one and his behavior was never checked
and they claimed they got the power to
do this from their position as the head
of a state the head of a country
irrespective of the limiting factors in
the constant right and one of the I mean
the main theme of the book is that we
either have a constitution that is the
law of the land or we don't and
obviously the answer from Roosevelt and
Wilson were yeah well you know I'm the
law right so Roosevelt and Wilson I mean
they're different parties they come from
different regions of the country when
regions regional differences were much
stronger
he went to Woodrow Wilson the college
that he was president of it he was a
rabid racist Theodore Roosevelt was a
racialist in other ways he believed in
the supremacy of the so-called white
races which would preclude either we
would not have had membership in his
understanding of the white race correct
I would not have been admitted to
Princeton if he were still president of
it so where was their similar worldview
coming from because they you know I and
discuss the role of how they viewed
elites they thought that they could
uplift people's lives by telling them
how to live their lives so these two
presidents and the government under them
stole freedom of choice from individuals
poor as well as wealthy and in return
gave them a set of values and parameters
in which they could live their lives
believing that this would uplift
everybody's lives are they are they
wrong about that
I mean just on an empirical basis
because there were rapid increases in
material circumstances for people
certain types of diseases were
eradicated there was great material
prosperity in the Progressive Era the
argument of the book is it would have
been vastly greater had the federal
government not interfered neither of
them would recognize the truism that
government doesn't create wealth it only
consumes it they believed that by
redistributing wealth they could spread
the wealth of course as we know from
history we are as we tape this two days
after the re-election of Barack Obama to
the White House as we know from history
the redistribution of wealth creates
dependence on the people to whom it is
redistributed it doesn't incentivize
them to create their own wealth I've
argued that the reelection of the
president widget was in large measure
due to the fact that nearly half the
country receives most of its subsistence
from the other half sort of Jefferson
and Hamilton the only thing they agreed
on in public as far as we know when the
voters recognize that the public
treasury has become a public trough they
will only send a Washington people who
will promise to give them as much of the
pie as they can
this began under Wilson and Roosevelt
now it's an odd combination Roosevelt
was born with a spoon in his mouth
Wilson was born to a middle-class family
but Wilson rose to to wealth and
personal prosperity through academia
Roosevelt who never really worked the
way you and I did experienced wealth and
enjoyed wealth that came from his family
and the two of them sought political
power neither of them ever had excused
the phrase to get their fingernails
dirty neither of them ever experienced
participation in the risk of their own
personal wealth in order to get a return
on that investment
one was coddled by academia the other
was coddled by his own family and both
would meet at about the same time in the
same place which is the White House who
were other contemporaries
Roosevelt and Wilson who said no this is
absolutely the wrong way well Robert
Taft is a real enigma because his his
presidency is filled with language and
vetoes of legislation which shows in his
own mind a fidelity to the Constitution
and then of course William Howard Taft
has the misfortune of running against
Woodrow Wilson where Teddy is running as
a third party candidate because the
Republicans rejected him right and at
this point Taft who have been a protege
of Roosevelt they're now bitter and they
are there are bitter enemies absolutely
Roosevelt believes that the presidency
should be his Taft believes that
Roosevelt should stay in in retirement
and Taft of course was not only
Roosevelt's buddy but he worked for him
so you have Roosevelt was now clearly
going to take most of his votes away
from Taft facilitating the election of
someone he claims to dislike even more
though on paper and in reality agrees
with him Woodrow Wilson so the question
is because Taft ends up at a very nice
position after all this he's booted out
of the White House where does he end up
as the Chief Justice of the United
States which is tremendous power because
its lifetime power was this a deal did
he know he was going to get the chief
justice ship when he sort of sacrificed
his presidency so that TR could make the
comeback effort and Wilson could get the
presidency one will never know it is
Wilson of course who makes Taft the
Chief Justice and then as the Chief
Justice he has this metamorphosis he
starts out as a small government
libertarian and ends up justifying
through the typical circuitous route
that the courts have done this for
generations all the big government
legislation that the Congress enacted in
terms of those who would resist the
Progressive Era you have a cadre of
members of the House of Representatives
and Senators from the Midwest not from
the two coasts because the progressivism
is a hotbed in California and clearly it
is in the East Coast and it is in
Chicago almost like the hot beds of
Liberal Democrats today but you have a
cadre of members of Congress
from both parties and in both houses
from the Midwest who meekly resist this
and then it becomes obvious to them the
longer there they are the longer they
see what does dependency build votes and
so they they go onboard to the point
where today Mitt Romney supposedly
faithful to the Constitution can run for
president saying I'm going to maintain
Social Security Medicare Medicaid Amtrak
the post office the long list of crazy
entitlements that have the bankrupt that
it's something like 49 percent of
Americans live in households that get
direct money from the government this is
the dependent what the tipping point is
50 I mean once once there are more of
them than us they will use the tools of
the government the legal tools of the
government to to curb our liberty and
extract wealth from us I mean to hear
the president mock and belittle for
example David Charles Koch each worth
about thirty five billion dollars
forgetting that together they employ
several hundred thousand human beings
what does he want them to do take that
35 billion it's 70 billion combined and
put in a shoe box and all those people
will be out of out of work and the
government can take whatever it wants on
the shoe box and give it away to those
people who used to earn nice incomes
themselves you see this is a problem
what is the theory of social change in
your previous book you were getting it
seemed more and more radical of saying
you know there are times where we just
have to say no to the government and you
were almost implying you know if not
violent revolution a refusal a kind of
thorough like refusal to to go along and
to throw your body on the machine well
how do we change things or how do you
can't really throw your body on the
machine when the machine has the
majority behind it I mean we know for
example sometimes the Machine doesn't
have the majority behind it two days ago
we witnessed in Colorado for example the
referendum on the ballot which legalized
the possession of marijuana by adults
for all purposes this was after the
legislature had defeated it so this is
literally the people going above the
government they have supposedly elected
to to serve them to work for them so
that's one way you can get around the
machine
but at the same day this happened Barack
Obama amassed maybe 44 or 45 percent of
the electorate behind his big government
the Constitution doesn't matter I can
give away all the wealth that I can get
my hands on so at some point this will
collapse at some point will be like
Greece great portion of the populace
dependent on the government and the
government unable to borrow money and it
knows it can't print anymore because you
need a wheelbarrow to buy a loaf of
bread like the Vermont Republic where
does that lead to that leads either to
dictatorship or to violence and that
will prove the wisdom I'm not calling
for revolution I don't want to get
arrested by the feds as soon as I leave
this home but I will leave right that
that proves Jefferson's statement that
the blood of patriots has to be
sprinkled on the tree of revolution he
said once in every generation we haven't
had anything like this since the Civil
War what are the ways to turn things
around before it gets to you know before
we tell everybody to go logging well
they the Colorado example may be
beneficial in unanticipated ways it may
demonstrate and I'm not a crusader for
marijuana I am a crusader for personal
freedom I am a crusader for I can do
what I want with my own body not talking
about abortion because I believe that's
another body inside a woman's but that's
another subject for later if you wish
but but the marijuana one is a great
example because the unforeseen
consequence here aside from telling the
feds to take a hike aside from the
people of Colorado telling their own
state government to take a hike is the
economic consequence if Colorado
succeeds marijuana will be far less
expensive in Colorado than it is today
that will drive the demand for marijuana
from the Mexican cartels so this might
be an experiment that would open up the
eyes of governments in other states
stated differently if you were to take a
poll amongst various interest groups in
America who wants to legalize marijuana
I dare say the group that most wants to
do it law enforcement because they
realize it's a good that they're
battling against a tide this is against
human nature people are ultimately going
to put in their bodies what they want
this is a waste of their resources
they're far better
catching a bank robber than they are
catching a user of marijuana so social
experiments at the state level may open
up the eyes of the Victorian phonies and
Nanny Staters around the country to
realize that freedom produces more
wealth and prosperity and happiness than
government controlled well we'll leave
it there thank you
Judge Andrew Napolitano your most recent
book is Theodore and Woodrow how two
American presidents destroyed
constitutional freedom I hope your book
helps restore some constitutional free
always a pleasure I thank you for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]